dallas keiko wants to establish that
straight change and certainly the cutter
on for his sick start era a touch over
four last time out he threw it very well
had really good command hopefully more
the same and there's a key matchup
got him working strike three right down
central
and reyes goes down
shane bieber towing the rubber for the
indians tonight he will be the northeast
ohio ford dealers indian starting
pitcher he beat the white sox earlier
that was on april 13th complete game
shutout
swing and a miss he blew it right by him
and that's a great start for shane one
down
came back with another beautiful
breaking ball and strikes him out two
away
swinging a miss with another
incredible breaking ball and shane
bieber starts the game by striking out
the side
number of at-bats here means a very
advanced hitter as he rips this ball to
center and a face hit and a bobble by
rosario but no chance for mercedes to
advance uh what a great
awareness of breaking balls mercedes has
not going
at him as he struck him out and that's
why that runner was not going
to strike out as many as bieber does
you don't want to run yourself right out
of the inning
so now it'll be interesting to watch all
night how many strikes does robert get
to hit in this game
that is one of them and robert shoots it
to right center oh a needless effort by
rosario's going to get the sox a chance
at a run mercedes on the way home he is
and robert gets an rbi
out of an errant dive from rosario it's
one nothing
that should have been first and third
and instead it's one-nothing socks
mercedes really is a dh even though he's
listed as a catcher the pitch
swing and a miss it looked like he went
around on a slider away bieber just
stayed with it so
game should be scoreless but ahmed
rosario tried to make a spectacular play
and it costs the indian to run
as good as any
bullpen in the game has struggled
the pitch a breaking ball swung on line
to right and a base hit
so a hanger and ximena's straightened it
out
indians have their first base hit
bases are loaded for jose ramirez
ramirez and the hitters count the pitch
and he grounds one back up the middle
base hit left center ximena's will score
hernandez around third he'll come home
throw into third beating it with a slide
as luplow and jose ramirez with a ground
ball single back up the middle
yes put the indians on top two to one
the pitch
and it swung out a bouncer to third
charged there by montana on the run
throws to first to get reyes breaking on
the play was luplow he scores
and reyes gets his team-high 18th rbi on
the slow roller to third that moncada
made a nice
charge glove and throw across the body
to get him
ramirez goes to third but the indians
lead three to one
and the indians have made keiko pay the
supreme price
two walks in the inning and they both
came around to score
and now eddie rosario with two down
ramirez at third indians on top three to
one the left-hander against the
left-handed hitting rosario breaking
ball swung on rip to center a two-out
rbi single into scores ramirez and eddie
rosario with his 14th rbi
lefties have a better shot
nick madrigal on two and two down the
right field as he'll get down
off of luplow
madrigal checks up at second base and
nikki two strikes strikes again
now anderson bieber to ta
he went fastball tim shoots it to right
field
luke loads up with it here comes
madrigal and the sox have run number two
the comeback trail being paved by the
nine and one hitters
long hold from beaver tim runs pitches
outside the throw
is somewhere up the red line
and tim seals second base
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh yeah locked him up
and eaton is the sixth strikeout victim
of shane bieber already tonight
go on up the middle that is into center
field tim's gonna score
johan on two strikes makes it four to
three as the pitches mount for shane
bieber tonight in a higher scoring
soiree than we expected
and no stride at all but a good uh good
sequence seven strikeouts for shane
bieber
white sox get it there
swing and a miss he struck him out and
shane bieber has now set a new major
league record
with his 18th consecutive game of eight
strikeouts
and how often do you see it tim does an
intro
for an award show
and he leads off the inning with a base
hit
he's one for one in that situation we
don't need harry doyle for that
struck him out anyway
so shane bieber had to work hard for it
gets the first out of the inning
two and two it's a fastball and it's
grounded through the right side
yasmani went to the top shelf for a base
hit to right
[Applause]
oh yeah ring them up with a fastball
and the one-two
swung out and missed he went fishing and
came up empty 11 k's for shane bieber
marshall's ready in the pitch a swing of
the drive deep right field back at the
wall as eaton he leaps it's gone
and jose ramirez with a huge insurance
run there a solo homer to right that's
his seventh
and it gives him three rbis tonight and
15 on the year
and the indians now lead the white sox
by a score of five to three here in the
eighth
righty-righty match-up
clause pitch to anderson
right back to second base euchaing
throws them out book it the indians go
to chicago and take the series opener
shane bieber gets to win his third and
emanuel clause nails it down in the
bottom of the night for his fifth save